The last book you're
reading in this course
is about great journalist Nick Lemann.
It's called redemption,
the last battle of the civil war.
That seems to be a contest right now
in writing about and publishing
about the violence of reconstruction.
It's really been discovered by American
publishers and certainly by American
writers and in less
than three new books out
on either the Colfax massacre,
which we'll talk about in a minute or
what lemon does mostly in his book,
which is the story of Mississippi,
sometimes called the shotgun policy,
sometimes called the Mississippi plan,
but in effect the coup d'etat whereby
the White Democrats of Mississippi took
back control of that state
largely by terrorist violence,
political violence in 1875 the
titles of these books strike me
redemption,
the last battle of the civil war,
Charles Lane's book,
the pop,
good journalistic popular writer,
a whole book in the Colfax massacre,
current title,
the day freedom died one day and
there's another book by a young New York
private high school teacher.
Proof that good books
can be written by anyone.
The Colfax massacre, the untold
story of black power, white terror,
and the death of reconstruction.
All those titles are true.
It's not the redemption of course that
you hear Button Bob Marley's redemption
song,
but am I recommended you put Marley on
while you're reading about this stuff?
It might be a nice antidote.
No,
I'm not going to sing it,
but I'm gonna start with
a very brief little poem.
One of the best illustrations in poetry.
I know of this idea that
revolutions can go backward,
that revolutions usually
do go backwards for awhile.
That revolutions always cause counter.
It's a poem by Langston Hughes.
He wrote it right near the end
of his life in 1965 note the date
he entitled it emancipation
and then a subtitle. Long view. Negro
two simple versus emancipation.
In 1865 cited through the
telescope of dreams looms larger,
so much larger,
so it seems than truth can be,
but turn the telescope around,
look through the larger in and wonder
why what was so large becomes so small.
Again,
the metaphor is powerful.
If vexing,
look through the opposite
end of a telescope.
Look back at history and not forward and
wonder why was what was such a dream,
what was so large,
it can become so small again
now,
and I'm
on that 15th Amendment Pass that I
talked about briefly the other day.
There were just amazing celebrations in
18 set when it was finally ratified in
1870 all over the place.
Um,
I only saw it a couple,
um,
grant and his message to Congress in
effect said reconstruction was now largely
over Frederick Douglass.
Though he wasn't thrilled with the
fact that it was the most conservative
version of the 15th amendment and so on.
Nevertheless said we can now
breathe a new atmosphere.
We have a new earth beneath
and a new sky above.
That's a dream.
One Republican newspaper called
it the nation's second birth,
second founding
and Wendell Phillips,
the again the Massachusetts abolitionists
said it was now the real birthday of
the nation because now the declaration
of independence applied to all know that
was placing a great deal of hope in a
somewhat limited amendment to say the
least. That's 1870 now go
ahead. Just five years with me.
This is the period now of
southern redemption defined
of course as the southern
White Democratic Party's counterrevolution
and taking back control of its state.
Governments happens very
quickly in some southern states.
Some are redeemed as early as 1870 by
the Democrats and the last three or so,
not until 1876 77 but think
of what you just heard there,
that that almost unfathomable hope
rooted in this voting rights amendment.
And then listen to this statement
from the floor of Congress,
one of the most brilliant young black
who got himself elected among those
hundreds of got elected among the
16 who got elected to Congress,
John Roy Lynch,
a former slave self taught.
He educated himself like Frederick
Douglass. There's, there's,
there's mysteries about
the brilliance of this guy,
but he's elected to Congress when he's
26 from Mississippi under Mississippi's
radical reconstruction government.
So long as it lasted,
he's still there in 1875 and
on the floor of the congress,
which was then,
as you'll see in a moment after the
74 election now ruled by a majority of
Democrats.
He looks them in the eye and he says,
think of it for a moment.
My colleagues,
when I leave my home in Mississippi,
to come to the capitol of the nation,
to take part in the deliberations of
this house and to participate with you in
making laws for the government
of this great republic.
I am treated not as an American citizen,
but as a brute force to occupy a filthy
smoking car both night and day with
drunkards, gamblers and
criminals. And for what?
Not that I am unable or
unwilling to pay my way.
Not that I am obnoxious in my personal
appearance or disrespectful in my
conduct,
but simply because I happen
to be of a darker complexion.
Now, here's the irony and the
point, the majority of those men,
he was speaking to that
day in the congress,
in their minds when they heard him say it,
to the extent they listened,
when he said that, I think we
can safely assume we're thinking,
yeah, that's just exactly the
way you should be treated.
No.
1873 for the moment.
Uh,
the day freedom died according to Charles
Lane's book is the day of the Colfax
massacre.
That day,
I wouldn't quite say freedom died on
one day. That's a little a historical,
but so be it. That's probably
a publisher's title more
than an author's title.
But April,
1418 73 is in some ways,
one of those days we could call in
American history a day of infamy.
The Supreme Court that day,
at least it's the date of the decision,
even though it was Easter Sunday,
handed down his decision,
five to four in the slaughterhouse cases,
so called a collection of five
cases that came out of Louisiana,
which was the courts first major ruling
on the civil war amendments on the of
the 13th,
the 14th and the 15th amendments
that day, same day,
Easter Sunday and Colfax.
Louisiana,
a town,
not very big name for Schuler Colfax,
the vice president of the United States
and the grant administration in grant
parish, renamed by the republican
regime where you list these grant.
The largest mass murder of Americans
ever in American history occurred in the
political violence stemming from the
divided election in Louisiana back in the
fall of 1872 now nine 11 of course,
killed more Americans.
We can get caught up in categories of
what is domestic violence and foreign
violence and so forth,
but this is the largest mass murder of
Americans in our history so far as we can
tell.
That divided election produced in effect
two competing governments in Louisiana,
the republican regime,
which per did win the election for
all practical purposes in spite of the
tremendous political violence committed
against particularly black voters in
that fall 72 election,
but it's still called fusion ticket of
basically a kind of white supremacists
coalition also claimed to
be the legitimate government
of Louisiana and in this
situation of essentially and ongoing
vigilante war throughout many of the
parishes,
counties of Louisiana,
a standoff took place in Colfax.
I'll come back to that in a moment.
Yeah.
But back to the slaughterhouse
case that came down that day.
It wasn't the end at testing
of the privileges and
immunities clause of the 14th
amendment.
In 1869 the city of New Orleans under
its republican state government created a
corporation to move the
slaughterhouse of New Orleans.
They're actually, I had never been a
legitimate slaughterhouse in New Orleans.
What the butchers of New Orleans would do,
the white butchers of New Orleans would
do is they heard the hogs through the
streets of New Orleans and basically
they'd butcher the things wherever they
wanted to and they always threw all the,
it gets ugly.
All of the old fall from the hogs into
the Mississippi River up river from the
city before the river reached the
main water pipeline into the city.
This has long been a problem.
Long been set,
a series of complaints and so this was
an attempt that clean government and
clean cities,
the city and the state backing it up,
created a corporation.
They created a new slaughterhouse.
They moved across the Mississippi River
and downstream from the city for health
reasons.
They put in a a state appointed inspector
and the white butchers of
New Orleans were angry,
some bushes and some critics charge. This
was a monopoly and an unfair practice.
25 butchers brought suit with support
from the reviving Democratic Party,
white butchers,
the lower courts in this particular suit
found in favor of the new corporation.
It was appealed to the u s supreme court.
It got on the docket in
72 it was decided April,
1418 73
it was a five to four decision seemingly
on the surface that when you read it,
it's like many court decisions.
It's a bit boring at first five cases
from butchers and so on and so on.
And you want to,
what the hell is this about?
And then you keep reading and you
realize it became a fundamental decision.
Justice Samuel Miller for the majority,
argued that the 13th and 14th
amendments were intended.
This was the good part of the decision
to end slavery and advance the rights of
the Friedman. But he made a
sharp, just in other words,
not to protect a bunch of
white butchers in New Orleans.
And by the way,
the lead lawyer for the butchers
in the slaughterhouse cases
was none other than a man
named Johnny Campbell. Uh,
Georgia born former member
of the supreme court.
He had been part of the six men majority
in the dred Scott decision of 1857
resign his position on the u s supreme
court in 1861 to go home and fight for
the confederacy.
He didn't fight on the battlefield.
He became assistant secretary of state
and the confederacy and serve through in
that position and other high ranking
official positions in the confederate
national government throughout the
civil war. And when the war was over,
he was one of those high
ranking confederate officials.
Denied the right to vote
disfranchised for up to four years.
He was part of the final set of amnesty
and pardons that Andrew Johnson enacted
just before leaving office in spring of 69
and Campbell and made it as business as
a redeemer now in the south to Swart and
fight reconstruction at every turn.
He hated black suffrage.
He hated black people.
He was a very white supremacist.
He took this case on because he
wanted to crush reconstruction.
He even argued,
by the way,
in the slaughterhouse cases which
Miller turned right back on his head.
He even argued that the rights of the
butchers were being under the 13th
amendment.
They said that he said that these butches
were now being forced into a form of
involuntary servitude because they had
to take their hogs across the Mississippi
and of them down river.
It was violating their right to make a
proper livelihood by their own individual
choice.
Okay,
and frankly, folks, I read this decision
this morning. I got through most of it.
If you want to read the
origins of our modern day uses,
and some would say
misuses of civil rights,
language and legislation in our own time,
the ways in which some American
politicians, lawyers, judges,
et Cetera, pundits, et
Cetera, et Cetera, et Cetera,
have appropriated the language of
the modern civil rights movement,
especially the language of the
content of our character too.
Sometimes some scurrilous ends.
The roots of that are in John Campbell's
arguments in the slaughterhouse cases
in 1873 Miller through the 13th
amendment argument back at,
at Thompson and told him in
effect to well stick it somewhere
now, however, back to Miller's
opinion in, in a five, four case.
The real importance of the slaughterhouse
case is that even though Miller argued
that the purpose of these amendments
were to, were to advance, uh, uh,
black freedom and the
rights of the Friedman,
he nevertheless made a clear distinction
between national and state citizenship
in these years. We don't
even think him. Well,
I don't think we think in terms
of the day of our states citizen.
Do you think of yourself as a
citizen of the state of Virginia?
Maybe you do.
I don't.
Maybe today in town Sylvania
where people are voting in droves,
they're thinking of their citizenship
was Pennsylvania and I don't know.
But we tend to think of terms
of citizenship now from the,
certainly in the early 21st
century is a national phenomenon.
One has Portuguese or,
or,
or German or American or whatever,
Brazilian citizenship.
And in some countries dual and so on.
Rarely do we think of ourselves
as citizens of states,
but they did in the 19th century.
Now what Miller did in this decision
though was a bit weird in retrospect,
he named various national
privileges and immunities.
That's the language of the 14th Amendment,
uh,
like entering the nation's ports
or protection out on the high seas.
The ability to run for federal office
and to travel to the seat of government
and so on.
But he never mentioned basic civil rights,
access to public facilities, et
Cetera, et Cetera, et cetera.
He never mentioned the right to vote.
He said all of those rights are only
under the jurisdiction of the states,
not the national government.
In other words,
traditional federalism.
This separation of what states can
control, like the right to vote,
like what is the civil rights,
which civil rights,
what kinds of equality or it'd be
adjudicated in court would be left to the
states
slaughterhouse set in motion.
This federal retreat, at least in
the courts, and it's a retreat,
is already happening elsewhere
from Miller's zone definition,
ironically of the meaning of the 13th and
14th amendments back to Colfax Colfax,
Louisiana, April, 1418 73.
I don't have time for the,
all the gruesome details of this massacre
and I'll spare you the most of it,
but it is in some ways in the
American mee Lai massacre, uh,
Katyn forest massacre with the
Soviets did in 1944 and Poland,
it's a, it's one of these
authors of this new book,
I think a bit inappropriately
uses the term genocide,
that it was a result of
a wish for genocide. Um,
it is mass murder by any definition.
What happened is that where these two
competing governments in Louisiana,
Democrat fusion government,
the Republican government,
both would appoint sheriffs
in the same parish.
So there was the Republican sheriff who
was black and there was the democratic
sheriff who was white, uh, local
officials of all kinds of being appointed.
Well,
what happened is that the violence in the
countryside got so bad in grant parish
that the blacks in the area began leaving
their cabins and leaving their small
farms and they came into Colfax because
Colfax had become a symbol of protection
and safety for blacks and the Great Red
River district of central Louisiana.
By the way,
the Red River region of central Louisiana
with some of the richest soil in all
of the south. It was a tremendous
sugar and cotton plantation region.
Several thousand acres of that Red River
district right around Colfax was zone
by a white land owner name of
Willie Calhoun, William Calhoun.
He was the son of a Meredith
Calhoun who had been a very,
very pro slavery, huge slave holder
before the civil war, but his son, Willie,
who had been raised in part in Europe
because his parents kept living half,
half the time in Paris as a kid
was badly, terribly injured.
His back was broken.
He spent his life as a hunchback
and God only knows how he came by,
his sympathies and his beliefs
in the rights of former slaves.
But he became a union during the civil
war in an area where it was not healthy
to be a union and the Red River
district and after the war was over,
Willy Calhoun became an early and often
scale away or Republican and he in
effect turned over much of
his land without even selling
it to the settlement of
hundreds and hundreds of
Friedman and their families.
Willie Calhoun would spend the Colfax
massacre watching probably 150 odd blacks
murdered in cold blood as a kind
of a prisoner on his front porch.
But at any rate,
black gathered and Colfax for weeks
before the spring of 73 cause it was,
it had been at least a co or a,
the Calhoun landing as it was called,
had been a place of safety.
Blacks took over the courthouse in Colfax.
They occupied it,
they'd collected lots of weapons,
they were ready.
They build trenches all the
way around the courthouse.
They were ready for
battle and it is battle.
They got from a huge mob of
disparate para military whites,
many of whom were for four
former confederate soldiers,
many of whom are former
members of the Ku Klux Klan.
Some now called themselves
knights of the white community.
Then went by all kinds of different
names and what had happened on April 14th
was indeed in effect,
a pitched battle.
The whites had a cannon,
lots of weapons.
Blacks couldn't hold them off.
They fled into the courthouse.
The whites captured a black men and
forced him to take a torch and they said,
we'll kill you or you take the
torch and light the roof on fire.
He let the roof on fire and the
courthouse began to burn down,
which of course smoked most of
the blacks out of the courthouse,
although a few stayed and were burned
to death, hiding under the floorboards,
and as they came out,
many of them were executed right around
the door before the thing was over that
night,
the estimate runs from
about 82 possibly as high.
We'll never really know
as 150 blacks were killed.
Most of them execution style.
Most of them will shots to the head.
Many of them shots to the back of their
heads and many of them in the wake of
being shot, uh, having
their bodies mutilated
the first representatives of the
Louisiana state government, uh,
the Republican will,
Louisiana state government arrived 48
hours after the massacre and recorded one
after another corpse shot in the back of
the head and then shot many more times
and then somebody
mutilated and they kept us.
This is this kind of gruesome need to
describe you find in these reports.
They also described many of the bodies
being eaten by dogs and Turkey vultures.
Well,
Colfax led to a national sensation,
Harper's weekly and Leslie's weekly
had illustrated articles about it.
Within a week,
a famous pictures of blacks carrying
their dead home to bury them quotations
from women describing a woman describing,
dragging her son away from the dogs who
are eating his body and so on and so
forth.
And it led to a national investigation
of federal investigation led by the US
attorney. The Republican appointed
us attorney in New Orleans,
who's name was James Beckwith,
a northern born new England
old abolitionists fellow with a good deal
of zeal who heroically tried to bring
indictments and prosecutions.
There were indeed many indictments,
but only three convictions
in the wake of Colfax.
It took over two years
and it led to the second great
Supreme Court case that turned around
reconstruction.
That case first argued in Louisiana
was for the three men convicted
of leading the Colfax massacre.
One of the names was a man
named William Cruickshank Cru,
I. K. S. H. A. N. K. I don't
think I put it on the outline
or did, I guess I didn't.
Sorry.
In the United States versus Cruickshank,
the u s supreme court took up the case
of these prosecute these convictions in
Louisiana. The court, by this time,
early 1876 when the crook
shank case came down,
had a new chief justice, his name
was Morrison Remick. Wait, w.
A. T. E.
We've been appointed by grant and 1874
to replace the recently deceased salmon p
chase, who had been appointed
chief justice by Abraham Lincoln.
The court by 1876 was seven
Republicans and two Democrats.
Most of them now had been
appointed by Lincoln or grant.
This was a thoroughly
Republican Party Supreme Court.
Um, wait, by the way,
we've been through many Supreme Court
appointments in our recent lifetime and we
know how political these things can
get weight with grants. Fifth Choice,
the first two people he
asked turned him down.
I don't want to be on the Supreme Court.
There's no political future.
Their Supreme Court justice in these
years often ran for president while they
were on the court and it's, they don't do
that. At least they don't do that. Now,
the next two people he appointed or he
wanted to appoint were turned down by the
Senate way, was his fifth
choice. Nobody ever heard of it.
He was known in Ohio,
but as one of his own supreme
court colleagues called him
said, wait, was quote at the
front rank of second rank lawyers.
Maybe it proves the old adage,
apologies to anyone from Ohio.
You know, the old saying, Ohio has had
more presidents. I think even in Virginia.
Some are born great,
some achieve greatness,
so I'm just coming from Ohio,
Morrison.
Wait,
we'll write the opinion in a nine zero
decision unanimous decision and the
Cruickshank case.
This was a test,
this case now of really the enforcement
act passed in 1870 the enforcement act
as part of the Ku Klux Klan acts
authorizing the federal government
to enforce the right to vote with
military action if necessary in the south.
This was a case now testing that also
of course testing the 14th and 15th
amendments,
the court decision and Cruickshank
found the indictments had said faulty.
It overturned two of
the three convictions.
It ruled that those immortal phrases
of due process and equal protection,
those two great clauses in the fort
and then part one of the 14th amendment
applied.
They said only to state actions and
not to the actions of individuals.
If a man murders another man in Colfax,
Louisiana in a, in a, in a
political way or any other way,
that's a state matter.
Even if it's around voting,
it's a state matter.
Not a federal matter can be
adjudicated in federal court.
Federal government does not have the
power to enforce the right to vote,
the right to civil rights and so on.
The Cruickshank case,
the implications of the Cruikshank
case immediately were obvious.
It meant number one,
that mass murder,
one unpunished in the United States to
and meant that blacks increasingly not
would be at the mercy of now
hostile state governments.
Back when Justice Miller wrote
that decision in slaughterhouse,
there was still a lot of
republican regimes and he's not,
he claimed to his dying day he was
leaving adjudication to states under
sympathetic Republican governments.
Yeah,
but Justice Miller or what if the
government's no longer sympathetic?
What if it's run by Klansmen?
And three,
it opened up. Crude now opens
up as a federal court decision,
all manner of discriminatory laws passed
by what will be democratic redeemer
governments in the southern states.
Why was there a nine zero decision in
1876 on this with seven of the justices
appointed by Lincoln and grant and so on?
Well one,
you have to realize that by 75 and 76
when these guys were were adjudicating
this decision,
there was a tremendous amount of just
flat out fatigue with reconstruction.
And I've been to all,
I've been to a lot of your sections now,
and I've heard you say the same thing,
and I'm not chastising you,
I'm not,
but sometimes we, we, we
read back into the past,
even our own fatigue with certain issues,
they were sort of fed up
with reconstruction in the
north. Well, yeah, they were.
Look at the consequences.
Yeah,
it's clear.
And even in their own writings that many
of the justices just wanted to get rid
of reconstruction and
leave it to the south.
It's signaled now,
most importantly,
a phoner makes this point in the one
little paragraph he gives you on the
Cruickshank case,
it's signal now with the federal
government was ineffective exiting
reconstruction. Certainly the
supreme court was, and his phone,
her says terror was given a green light
anywhere that is state government was
unwilling
to enforce the law or protect people.
Now,
why was radicalism waning in the 1870s
or even at the beginning of the 1870s.
What is about about the grant years,
especially the second grant
administration that leaves, you know, the,
this pay practically paves these
roads to a southern redemption,
a southern counterrevolution?
Well, there are many factors,
and let me kind of run
through them and then focus,
especially on the scandals for a moment.
And then on this larger question of,
of violence, in case you haven't
heard enough about violence
and mean, first of all,
there's the panic of 1873, um,
which set in,
in the spring of 1873,
a major economic depression that
hit the country, the entire country,
and led to a great deal of
labor, strife, and violence.
Okay?
It meant in the wake of the well in the
midst of the panic of 73 and [inaudible]
74 [inaudible] 75 that the issues now
that politicians were most concerned about
and the voters were most concerned about,
particularly in the north,
were things like currency,
tariffs, unemployment,
railroad subsidies, labor strife. Whether
a union had the right to strike here,
the right to strike there and across
the great Midwest among farmers.
The biggest issue was the price of wheat,
which dropped from $2 a barrel
to 50 cents in a year and a half.
Okay.
Wages for manufacturing laborers in the
United States in a year and a half drop
by 50% across the country.
That's for those who kept their jobs.
The panic of 1873 shifted people's mind
to say the least.
Yeah.
Then there's the factor of the grant,
the nature of grants presidency,
the way in which granted himself
even defined the presidency,
grandchildren remember, was a rather
reluctant politician. At first.
He actually got a little better at it.
Then his historical reputation is
sometimes led us to believe grant could be
very political, although he did have this
idea that the presidency ought to be,
especially in these crisis years with
the tremendous bitterness bloody shirt
tensions after the
civil war and after all,
he's the general that won the war and
obliterated Virginia that the president
ought to be.
Now just basically a caretaker ought
to have as few opinions as possible.
A caretaker presidency,
not so much a leader as a unifier.
No,
he is hands off approach to so many things
of course is what in part led to the
scandals that are so long have long,
so long been associated with him or
at least with his administration.
I would argue that grant has gotten
to some extent a bad rap from some
historians.
Although if you look at any of those
lists that come out every year when they
survey historians, the greatest
presence, the worst presidents, you know,
Lincoln's always at the top
and then you get to Fdr.
Now Reagan has always in the top three
for reasons I don't even want to discuss.
A
lot of airports are named forums.
I guess that's why at any rate, um,
enough on that grant is always
down here near the bottom.
I can't resist this. The great
American cynic of the 19th century,
one of our greatest historians and
one of our most beautiful writers,
but what a cynic. Henry Adams,
son of Charles Francis Adams,
grandson of Quincy,
great grandson of John.
This was his description of grant
and he was living the
grant administration.
Grant had no right to exist.
Yeah,
he should have been extinct for ages
that 2000 years after Alexander the Great
and Julius Caesar,
a man like grant should be called and
should actually truly be the highest
product of the most advanced
evolution made evolution ludicrous.
The progress of evolution from President
Washington to President grant was alone
evidence enough to upset Darwin.
Grant should have lived in
a cave and Warren Skins,
Ooh,
that's Cole
and unfair,
but under his leadership,
a whole series of four or five different
scandals that sort of set the standard
for scandal to come in American history.
Although we've,
we've had some much worse one since then.
Some of these,
most of them were of course financial.
There's almost no sex in the grant
scandal years so far as we can tell. Um,
the first one is the gold scandal.
This was an attempt to corner of the
gold market by one Jay Gould and James
Fisk. He's are Wall Street
guys in New York is an 1869.
Right after grant took office.
They did indeed corner the market on goal.
They tried to buy up all the gold in
New York and then they plan to force
bankers and business people to buy the
gold from them and inflated prices.
It's an old cornering a trick.
They uh,
they made $11 million in three weeks
doing this in the 19th century.
Yeah.
They were eventually selling that
goal than $163 and 50 cents per ounce.
And the only way to break their corner
was suddenly, cause it happened so fast,
it was for the federal government
to begin selling all of its goal,
put it on the market,
get the prices down,
grants brother-in-law never point
your brother in law to anything able.
Corban was that sort of personal emissary.
He assured and promise the plotters,
Gould and Fisk that uh,
he had influence on grant and the grant
would never permit the government's goal
to be sold,
but he was wrong.
And grant did allow it to be
sold. And then grants person, uh,
grants a treasury secretary,
George Barnwell got involved.
The scandal finally
broke open in the press.
And though nothing ever really happened
to Goulder Fisk setting in motion a
history of who gets caught and who doesn't
get caught in the Wall Street world.
It did,
it was the first scandal of its kind to
begin to lead to cries of civil service
reform, which became, uh, uh,
a big rallying cry and the 1870s
then there was the whisky ring.
Man,
this was all fashion just
on a Delta rated fraud.
This began in the early 1870s.
At first started in St Louis.
It was really a cartel,
what we in modern times would
call the creation of a cartel.
These were whiskey distillers all over
the country who banded together to cheat
the US government out of excise taxes.
You know the luxury tax on Whiskey,
the way that they did it,
as many distillers were forced to join
this ring of people around the country or
have their businesses ruined,
join or we'll run you out of business.
The whisky ring had branch offices
all over the country and cities like
Milwaukee, a Peoria, New Orleans,
Chicago, Cincinnati in Washington,
in many other cities, north,
south, west, you name it,
and then they started bribing
the Treasury Department,
which of course is where
the excise taxes would,
would go to many officials
in the Treasury Department.
We're soon on the payroll
of the whisky ring,
especially the chief clerk of
the U S Treasury Department.
The man who kept the books,
one General Orville Babcock,
the president's private secretary
was implicated more than implicated.
He was involved. He was charged
eventually, although acquitted
grant entered a deposition on his
behalf and a good character and so on in
court, which he never showed his done.
He didn't really look at the facts.
He didn't look at the evidence.
The point of all this one is that
millions and millions of dollars in liquor
revenues were lost.
To the u s government from about 1870
to 1875 and most of that money went into
the pockets of whiskey distillers,
and a lot of it went into the pockets of
treasury department officials who were
themselves supposed to
be collecting the tax.
The estimate is that between 40
and $50 million it was grafted.
In this particular scandal scandal broke
in 1875 there were about 150 people
indicted in the liquor business.
About 85 people indicted
in the federal government.
There were 110 convictions,
although nobody served
terribly long in any prison.
And thirdly,
there's this thing called credit Moby lay.
This was the company that was first
chartered in 1859 as part of it was,
it was the finance company
for the Pennsylvania.
It was called the
Pennsylvania fiscal agency.
Originally it was the finance company
for the Union Pacific railroad that got
the greatest contract in American history
to build a transcontinental railroad.
The Union Pacific had a charter from the
federal government to build this great
railroad to the Pacific,
or possibly two or three of them
for each mile of track built.
The Union Pacific was to receive 10
sections of public land and from 16,000 to
$48,000 depending on how difficult
the terrain was to build on.
Yeah,
Union Pacific arranged the construction
contracts with its own from the wood
that had called credit Moby lay,
so that all government money
would get spent. You know,
the old routine,
if you get a grant,
make sure you spend it because
they won't give you as much.
Next time credit Moby lay and therefore
union Pacific made enormous profits.
The shares of stock and credit
and Moby lay skyrocketed.
And to keep the federal government in
line and to let this continue to go on
many congressmen,
we never know.
We'll never know exactly how many were
on the take with simply being bribed and
old fashion.
Handfuls of cash by the Union Pacific.
This scandal to broke in 1873
all kinds of people were accused,
including vice president Schuler.
Colfax Congress
reprimanded one government,
railroad agent and two Congressmen
and then just left it alone.
Uh,
so far as I know,
no one's ever really put a price tag on
the graph committed by the Union Pacific
and the credit Moby lake case.
This kind of spoils men economic,
financial corruption became rampant
in the grant years and again,
a huge political distraction away
from the issues of the south.
The issues of the Freedman,
the issues of reconstruction,
the other major paths to
southern redemption,
the success of this,
the white southern Democratic Party
was of course the uses of violence.
But before I give you a little more
litany and the level of clan terrorism,
think with me for just a moment.
What those radical Republicans originally,
almost none of whom are
really in power anymore.
That is Stevens died in 1869 Charles
Sumner dies in 1874 Benjamin wait is long
gone as a senator from Ohio,
the old leadership of the radicals is
really no longer there by 1874 when the
Democrats are going to throw the
Republicans out of the leadership of the
congress.
Anyway,
the thing with me for just a moment
back to what phone are called the the
radicals civic vision.
That civic vision again,
was rooted in Free Soil Ism,
unionism winning the war and
to some an anti and an ending,
slavery, emancipation, and then two at
least the beginnings of racial equality.
You cannot mistake that they believed in
at least the beginnings of that in the
13th 14th and 15th amendments,
but think for a moment
in the 19th century,
how would most Americans think
about the idea of equality?
I would argue that in our history,
this nation in the modern
world that probably tried
to do more about the ID of a
quality than perhaps any place else
has gone through three definitions of a
quality.
The first,
we might simply call a quality in
the eyes of God or natural rights.
The old enlightenment,
it's not from the inlet,
just from the alerts in the
epistles of Paul. It's, it's,
it's ancient in some ways,
but the idea that somehow you're
a born equal before God or nature,
well,
you have a natural capacity that's equal.
It doesn't say anything about human
affairs and understanding about government
or law.
The second kind of equality,
and it came into history.
Okay,
is it quality before law
that was never codified,
never spoken until the 14th amendment.
The equal protection of the law.
Okay?
That's where it begins. If there's a
third kind of equality in our history,
it's probably what we came
to Carl and the 20th century,
and especially in the civil rights
revolution in its wake and equality of
opportunity
in the 19th century.
Trust,
they never got to that one
and they didn't get terribly
far with the quality before law.
The radical Republicans
ideas we're up against.
And here you can just give up and say,
well,
you see what we tried to go too far too
fast. They were ahead of their times.
Gee Whiz, reconstruction failed.
Maybe it should have failed.
Can't do anything about it.
So be it how the lights went out for
75 or 80 years. But that's, you know,
some things are inevitable in history
if you're comfortable with that,
uh,
fine.
But the radical Republican analogy
at least set in motion a tradition.
The problem was they got
cornered themselves in,
they'll by their own language because
the language they got cornered by was the
language of guaranteed rights.
If you've guaranteed somebody,
uh,
beginnings of a quality in law,
what else is there to do?
If you and I are equal before the law,
at least the law says we're equal before
the law, what else can government do?
But the radical Republicans
in reconstruction launched
that question into our
history. Has No one ever had,
would have governments, old people,
and what do people,
governments,
the trouble of course was that
on the ground in the south,
the Klan and all of its imitators,
okay,
we're winning reconstruction by terror,
by political violence,
um, by intimidation.
Now you've read about the Klan. I've
given you a statistics on Klan violence,
especially in 1868 up through 1871,
but it was the first grant administration
and we've got to give grant credit for
this. And Henry, Adam should
have at least four out of this.
When he wrote that godawful passage,
the grant administration did act
in 1870 and 71 against the claim.
May 31st,
1870 it past the so called force
act or the first enforcement act.
It made it a federal offense to interfere
with any person's right to vote and
made it punishable in a federal court.
That's the very law.
The Crook Shank case is going to
come along six years later and say,
no federal government can
enforce that only the state can.
It's one of those moments you want to go
back into history and just grabbed some
people by the collar
and say, no, no, no, no.
Think of a think one more time,
but of course we can't do that.
February 28 80 71 second for sac
provided a machinery for the federal
supervision of registration
and voting in the south.
They had at least tried and finally they
passed what was called the Ku Klux Klan
Act. April, 2018 71
okay.
It authorizes the
president to use the army
and to suspend the writ of Habeas
Corpus wherever he deemed necessary.
If there was a state of insurrection,
which there was in South Carolina and
about 12 counties move the army and if
necessary to protect the safety
and security of elections.
Now under this authority of these
enforcement acts and the clacks,
approximately, uh, 3000 people,
mostly white southerners were
indicted for Klan violence,
murder, intimidation, torture.
Thousands were arrested.
Many of those 3000 indicted pleaded
guilty and got suspended sentences.
About 600 were convicted,
250 acquitted,
most received fines or
light jail sentences.
65 people were in prison for up to
five years in a federal penitentiary in
Albany,
New York.
All of them were out by 1875
before the Cruickshank case,
the thousands of people murdered
by the Klan. The thousands torture,
the thousands kept from voting.
65 people were prosecuted.
If you think back to the other day,
a quotation I asked you to keep in your
head on Frederick Douglass gives that
speech in 1875 imagining the following
year, the bice, the centennial,
the US independence,
and he worries about all the Hosannas
to American patriotism and independence.
And he says,
if war among the whites
brought freedom to blacks,
what will peace among the whites bring?
It is a peace among the whites.
That was happening by 1875
okay.
On Thursday, we'll move this toward
one of the ends of reconstruction.